here are three things you can use to
incentivize people to give you more
money today so the first thing is you
say hey if you prepay the services with
me I'll also add in a guarantee so if
someone does a payment plan there's no
guarantee if they prepaid there is one
the second thing you can do is add a
bonus up front so you say hey if you
prepay I'll also do this extra thing so
you get more for the same amount the
third thing that you can do is that you
can give a discount for prepayment so
maybe 10 or 20 off the total package for
prepayment that's fairly common but the
nice thing is you can actually combine
the first two with the third and say hey
not only will I give you a discount I'll
also guarantee or not only will I give
you a discount I'll also give you this
bonus so you're paying less and getting
more and so you give people an incentive
to pay you more today which improves the
cash flow in the business